[Music]
[Laughter]
welcome patreons to fight night
you can tell by the new intro music this
is something new
so we have referenced throughout this
year many of the caddy spats between our
favorite philosophers some of them are
petty some of them are personal and some
of them are actually theoretical
although that's probably in the minority
but i'm thinking of
derrida versus foucault
de luz versus foucault badew versus
deluz
jesus versus dillas
damn dallas seems to get into these a
lot despite uh his reputation being as
non-confrontational and rather generous
but
i don't know a lot of people write books
about why he's wrong but then we got
gatari versus lacan adorno versus mccoos
marcusa
bodriard versus everybody
there's g jack versus the cloud versus
judith butler
probably versus the early g jack soon
enough
spivak wrote against uh derrida or his
understanding of marx anyway there's an
endless series that could be done here
and we're kicking it off today
because it's also i think a good way of
getting clear about what they're being
spiteful about and where the actual
confrontation lies
and it's a good way to learn some of the
differences about their thinking
any thoughts on that okay so we're gonna
do a series
we're gonna do a series it might be
interrupted by other stuff but we
thought we'd do something a little
longer form each dealing with one
theorist criticizing another theorist
and if we don't get bored with it we
could go all the way back to shelling
versus hegel but today as the title said
we're looking at
baudrillard versus foucault
that one i actually find a bit sad since
they were like legit friends not just
like intellectual
colleagues as it were you know their
roommates for a little while and then
they broke apart but i had a quick
question actually and
anyone can jump in here
close to your face look how far it is
yeah but one of the weird things about
academics is that academics are really
very petty spiteful
precious people for the most part like i
can't think of
many academics who've handled being
criticized in a serious way by someone
else well uh usually the kind of
visceral reaction is
a combination of oh you're not even good
enough for me to respond to to and
blocking you on facebook yeah and then
well on that or or how dare you you know
criticize my genius right so i want to
know can anybody think of somebody who's
handled legitimate criticism
well
i'm not talking about like the petty
insults bad faith argumentation but like
somebody wrote a critique of their work
and they responded with
maybe not you know i agree but at least
like this was interesting or i kind of
can see where they're coming from i take
everything you just said as a personal
attack on me and i it was intended
i refuse to respond it is beneath me
[ __ ] you
one person criticized derrida it might
have been cyril and then derrida
responded
by
cutting up the entire the person's
entire essay was it cyril he cut up his
entire essay
and responded to him with only
quotations from him woven together into
an article
[Laughter]
yeah no it was uh the new york review of
books so i wrote um a review uh
basically dared his whole uber and
called him not quite a
pseudo-philosopher but close to a
pseudo-philosopher and this was shortly
after the whole cambridge controversy
uh where a bunch of big analytic
philosophers tried to keep daredevil
from receiving an honorary degree from
the institution so
tb fair he was probably feeling a little
bit attacked
by
that stream-a-thon
i mean you're already kind of setting
yourself up for a little bit of a
distorted perspective of these things by
taking these sorts of very well
publicized and like event-like
like encounters between big famous
academics as anything like a indication
of how they get along or how their ideas
are actually formed like a lot of these
communities of french writers like
whatever you got you got baudrillard
derrida barth buko delusion guterree
it's more like a it's like a community
of philosophers that are developing all
these ideas between each other
like these moments
are like exclamation points that like
punctuate the development of french
theory but
i don't i think they're very superficial
in terms of like indicative of these
people's like intellectual developments
or i mean of course you hear about
things like they fall they have fallings
out they stop talking to each other they
quit the french communist party which is
a pretty radical gesture for a french
intellectual but i mean i don't
i don't think it has a whole lot of
bearing
did you know i only learned this from
reading the introduction to the book
today which is
forget foucault
antagonistically titled but baudrillard
and guitaree were in the same maoist
group priests oh yeah
yeah i did not know that no yeah there's
always these interesting connections
between them yeah the the introduction
brings up a couple wow they work
together here and there i was gonna say
there's only three examples of like an
academic spat i know of where people
handled it with grace and maybe people
can come up with another one uh there
was malthus and ricardo in the 19th
century since apparently despite the
fact that they criticized each other
religiously
they were actually best friends uh they
will put that aside when they hung out
with one another then there was habermas
um
actually with daredev and then later on
with rawls apparently darada and
habermas got along pretty well near the
end despite like attacking each other
for years
and then i guess the last one uh
will probably be
uh rawls and nozick so nozick was a big
libertarian thinker in analytic circles
but yeah
he brought a lot of criticisms of rawls
rawls apparently liked the work
went back and forth and they were okay
with it but could people think of
anything else
well dairy does known andela's i guess
are they known for being not too egoist
yeah i've heard
compared to foucault who will read being
criticized today
i heard i heard that about darita too
like i i heard that he was like when
people were being generous or engaging
with his work he tend to be pretty
generous back with with people like i
know he would
like he would hang out with with
i think a few different interpreters of
him who disagreed with each other but he
would like still like so i'm thinking
about the the christian one uh who's who
is that villanova what's his name
and um and then she and then i think he
would also hang out with the other guy
like michael like nos or nass or
something like that and they both like
hated each other i think but
dario would like correspond with both of
them anyway
yeah
just cause they're theorists doesn't
mean they are above petty rivalries
i think that they enjoy petty rivalries
precisely because they're theorists it
might be incorrect that they actually
hated each other but i just know that
both of those interpreters disagreed
about what they thought darida thought i
think and then but like i think he would
still give them both time the time of
day well it's funny i posted a meme
today about hegel uh it's a guy trying
to pick up a girl by quoting hegel and
somebody said like isn't that a little
really unrealistic would people actually
talk about hegel during a date and i was
like one i've done it with my wife so
it's it is definitely possible but
number two i'm like i don't think you
understand how seriously people will
take the interpretation of higgle like i
was at a conference once where
after a couple beers
how to interpret the phenomenology of
spirit almost led two people to come to
blows with one another like they were
[ __ ] yelling and screaming and livid
about how to read this book
so um like people can actually get
really [ __ ] engaged by this [ __ ]
yeah for sure and i guess we're bringing
this all up obviously because uh i don't
like i think as a result of this book
right forgetfuco there was like quite a
rift i mean i don't know
the full background of the story but i
think uh like beaudrilliard was kind of
shunned by the french intellectual
circles is that right
well you can't come at foucault in the
70s he's at
college de france the premier school
he's king [ __ ]
still friends with the liz at this point
and he's enjoying also celebrity
so beaudry art younger the kind of
iconoclast extraordinaire he's
relatively unknown or not nearly as
popular anyway
but he comes at the king with an article
entitled as i said forgetfuco
and the easiest way to draw ire from
baudrillard in the first place is to
be a celebrity all at all
that's true let alone one that talks
about power so
what's that right so pills i'm hoping
letter cited in the matrix and stuff
right so pills i'm hoping you can kind
of explain the argument to me from this
because i mean i got i think i got the
basic outline from reading the
introduction and the and the and the
text but
you know i did i did i was reminded
because i guess i haven't been reading
french philosophy lately i was very much
viscerally reminded of the obtuseness of
sometimes the
way there's a lot of um you know there's
the typical thing where there's like
meanderings and like like kind of like
mentioning different views of different
things and like you can't really tell if
it's his view or if he's like presenting
someone else's view and he's clearly
talking about ideas of other
philosophers without naming them a few
times like i think a lot of delusion
concepts come up i think if i'm not
mistaken which i don't read the laws
never read to us so like that stuff was
it was unclear whether he was presenting
foucault's views deliza's views or his
views i don't know help me out here i
was shocked how clear this was yeah
terribly accessible
at least compared to his uh his later
work but he's much more direct about
what his arguments are than uh something
like the gulf war never took place
i also want to say that this is most
french essay i've ever [ __ ] read life
far and away since it literally included
a phrase like the political economy of
the phallus and i'm like only a french
philosopher could combine revolution and
sex together into a phrase like that
like the twin obsessions
oh yeah about a third of it is about
pornography so yeah right it also opens
saying foucault's writing is perfect
oh yeah that's true that was interesting
which is a very interesting yeah only
you could use perfect as an insult well
there it is well that's what i was just
gonna say without i didn't i i read the
introduction after reading the main text
and i noticed and and to me without
knowing obviously it did immediately
come across as sarcastic to me at the
beginning i don't know if that was
correct or not no i think it means it's
literally too perfect which is too
perfect which is why it doesn't because
it seduces you with its perfection it's
a perfect it's a perfect uh reflection
of the phenomenon that he's trying to
explain which for beaudry art is a sign
that what he's actually trying to
explain is probably something like dead
and irrelevant now well you can
definitely tell that when reading
foucault's books right like uh my
understanding of him as a kind of
theorist or like his meth his approach
right was that he was a bit of a
perfectionist right he would apparently
spend hours and hours um in various
libraries researching his topics and
write and rewrite his text and you can
really see that right uh you know victor
was making fun of french philosophy
earlier and i 100 sympathize with but
you read foucault's books and there's
actually a lot of literary virtues to
them right well foucault's way clearer
than this yeah's writing is generally
pretty clear i think i mean when it
comes to like when you on balance uh
like thinking about french philosophy
generally it's pretty easy i think yeah
and it has like vivid phrases right like
everybody remembers
the intro to uh discipline and punish
everybody remembers you know the history
of sexuality volume one where he's like
we must cut off the head of the king
people really remember you know the
panopticon and stuff about knowledge
power like he was very
precise and pretty uh in the way that he
constructed his books right and his
articles
i i find it all pretty difficult
yeah so pills like help me out here like
you know what's what's what do you what
do you take to be the main argument and
then and then i'm gonna see if what you
say is what i took away from it or not
well i thought i
we haven't really talked on this podcast
about may 68 yet so i was seeing this in
the context of may 68 so should i just
explain the thesis or
talk about may 68 first i think that's a
good idea whatev yeah maybe whatever you
think makes the most sense
okay so after
may 68 there was a big general strike in
mainly paris
and it was looking like there could be a
communist overthrow of the de gaulle
government
and it was crucial for the french left
because all the guys that we talk about
they were young a lot younger than
we know them from the heights of their
careers but they're all in like various
communist
parties some were maoist some are
marxist leninists and there was a
quite powerful
french communist party it wasn't winning
elections but it was like it was
relevant
so there's a general general strike
largely of students and the trade unions
and we don't need to go into too much
detail here but the radicals wanted to
uh overthrow the government or call an
election and
the pop the communist party this or
the way that the french left academic
left felt was that the communist party
betrayed the students because it settled
for
uh wage increases for for workers
rather than like revolution
so the radicals felt betrayed because
they had all this energy people were in
the streets barricading buildings and
all that and the communist party sold
them out so
to them this was
symbolically the left dying in in france
or the radical left dying in france so
then the response in theory to this uh
you can kind of tell is people don't
really know whether they're marxists
anymore unless you're like sart but
everyone else is trying to figure out
okay what do we do
to
be marxists now that the marxist party
in france is a lib party basically
um and obviously foucault has one sort
of answer to that delusion guitare and
anti-oedipus have one sort of answer to
that uh
baudrillard attacks both of them so this
is against both de losing atari
and foucault
mainly foucault because this previous
book was more against stella's guitari
but you have to read this entire paper
through desire what is desire
is it the is it the psychoanal
psychoanalysis desire of lack or is it
the delis desire of production and this
is what his main criticism of foucault
is here is foucault doesn't have any
desire he has no location for desire in
the subject because all there is is
power
and this is why he he criticizes this
text for being too or
it's basically uh foucault's history of
sexuality is the main reference but he
says it's too perfect because foucault
has this wide-ranging analysis bojar
calls it a spiral that starts at the
widest possible
social
layer like
actual institutions institutions uh the
church
psychiatric institutions that define or
they have they
proliferate power
and this goes all the way down to the
individual where you internalize power
and that's just what happens from top to
bottom in in a system of power and
that's what's too perfect right there's
no cracks reality is complete it's power
from the macro cosmic to the microcosmic
you can't make any
actions in the world because it's all
just power anyway so if power is
everything
then it's not really anything and
beaujord's quite incisive uh remark here
is that he's just describing capital
except he's mirroring capital and
describing capital is uh no longer
revolutionary activity it's just
mirroring the status quo and he says
actually the same thing about de las
that deliz wants to turn everything into
flows movement productivity well that's
the same thing that capitalism does so
beaujord's out radicalizing them i think
is his is his goal and saying you're
just copying the world around you
and admitting defeat basically yeah i
think in in setting the context the the
um
the the introductory essay
says that the
in reference to the 68 rebellion it says
the the introducer says here uh
the student rebellion has proved at
least one thing the french communist
party trade unions in the working class
the entire institutional left had ceased
to be revolutionary the communist
bureaucracy had not thrown its might on
the side of the student revolt instead
it pressed the besieged government for
salary increa increases
then it goes on to say no wonder french
post 68 thinkers like beaudrillard
looked elsewhere for revolutionary
alternatives failing to enlist their
allies they resolved to sleep with the
enemy and i think a little bit of this
uh
perfection that he's talking about the
way it just sort of mirrors the
functioning of power in actual societies
that's this idea of sleeping with the
enemy
it's almost like a new move instead of
starting a movement where we take it
down we almost like
penetrate inside and try to sort of
mimic
the flow of like i guess this is more
baudrillard's argument but what they're
doing is
mimicking the flow of power and the flow
of desire as a kind of flow of capital
yeah i want to say i thought this was a
really well done essay actually
i have issues with it and i don't think
it's true defucco's thought but it does
land some hits and we can get into why
later on but what i wanted to say is uh
i usually for my own interpretation of
code draw in thomas lemke's book um the
theory of governmentality um in michelle
co's writing where he tends to periodize
foucault and says look poco had this
early archaeological period where he's
talking about how knowledge forms itself
into discourses and language uh then
later on he has a
genealogical period that becomes more
overtly nietzschean uh where he talks
about how it is that discourse
instantiates itself in very material
kinds of power you know disciplinary
power biopolitics etc etc and then
there's a final phase into his work uh
which is an ethical turn uh and
formulations on the subject right uh how
it is that power now creates certain
kind of subjects uh who might be able to
internalize various forms of subjugation
uh or they might be able to be
transformed into subjects who
have the right ethos uh to engage in
projects of self-creation right and i
think lemke's periodization is really
helpful um but one of the things that
comes across it is that from reading
foot code this way is that bojar is kind
of right for co almost had a perfect
career right everything fits together
you can see the clear developments in
his work uh and he really comes across
looking a little bit
like a hedgehog sorry a a hedgehog
in the classy and berlinian typology
right somebody who's able to fit every
aspect of reality into this
ever-encompassing system uh and i think
it's not a coincidence that he was uh
good friends for a little while with the
liz uh who of the major
post-structuralist thinkers is the only
other one i can think of who really
comes close to building something like a
classical philosophical system right uh
but coke often comes close as well and
beaujolais in this essay comes across
very differently right he's much more of
a foxy character
it's much harder to pin down his work in
any way uh
he wrote
many many different books uh plenty of
which are quite imperfect
but you can always kind of see his ideas
on the run and developing
and he seems to almost be reacting
viscerally against
the systematic aspirations uh and the
archetectonic
mode of thought
that he still detects as being present
in foucault's thinking
so i think it might not even not
necessarily just be a philosophical
issue uh but even an aesthetic and a
personal one right he just doesn't like
this way of looking at things
and interestingly
uh foucault said when because budria
kind of ran this by him before he
published it and foucault said he would
respond
he didn't
apparently got pissy about it and didn't
respond to it the other criticism that
he never responded to is dary does and
darida just said that foucault is
reinstantiating metaphysics with this
power thing because what is if it's
everything
then it's not anything and you can't
deconstruct it
so those are the two critiques i think
victor you said these are the two
critiques that he never responded to and
they are saying much the same thing
um i wanted to give one quote
that i think sums it up
he says uh
this is actually you can tell in here
it's a critique of both delays and
foucault at the same time so buddha
actually had a quick question before you
give the quote i was just wondering
pills because i as a non-dilizion like i
was wondering when i was reading this is
it a coincidence that uh both de las and
foucault call themselves nietzscheans uh
that like that like bodriard's critique
is both at targeting them or is that
just kind of incidental
uh well i think beaudorado is very
nichian
also also i would say
but i guess i guess it depends on what
part of nietzsche you're talking about
because
you can also talk about
anichian metaphysics
too
or his or the historiography of
nietzsche and beaujolais is much more
like we need to have
to dis
disenchant
our theory i would think so that's one
nichian impulse as opposed to let's uh
let's trace the history of morality
which is kind of foucault's approach
right okay okay
yeah the uh
the uh
one who wrote the introduction to this
uh silvera lot ringer suggests that
budriard was uh
trying to out nietzsche foucault in some
ways here
let me give this one quote because it
it's it shows his attack on both uh de
luz and foucault at the same time
this compulsion oh this is beaujort by
the way this compulsion towards
liquidity flow and an accelerated
circulation of what is psychic
sexual or pertaining to the body is the
exact replica of the force which rules
market value
capital must circulate gravity and any
fixed point must disappear the chain of
investments and reinvestments must never
stop value must radiate endlessly and in
every direction
so
in saying that uh
i de or beaujourd is saying both
delizi's desire delusion qatari's desire
excuse me and foucault's power is this
kind of endless
um unbounded reproduction of itself
and that means that there's no way
inside or no way outside of it so
they're really just writing about the
thing that they should be
trying to do violence against so
beaujord as an iconoclast he thinks the
goal of theory is violence against the
status quo whereas he's saying that uh
these two are just reproducing the
status quo that's interesting yeah and
the reason there's no desire in foucault
is because power plays that role that's
kind of what he says he says they're the
same thing you can you can interchange
them and the and the
there's a nice metaphor in the
introduction that that the exchange
value between the two is is almost
nothing yeah delis didn't like that at
all he didn't like hearing that yeah
like you can just take one out for the
other and there's nothing gained or lost
which is a kind of interesting way to
look at theories if if all these
theories
sort of become these detached floating
signifiers that only just reference each
other and there's no
you know exchange value between them as
as we would think of exchange value as
being between the canadian dollar and
the american dollar and the australian
and whatever
if there's no if there's no exchange
value then there's no kind of motivation
to move between currencies because
they're all just kind of the same thing
it's kind of it's a pretty it's a pretty
bad uh
dis i'd say well that's funny because
like that is some type that is like um i
thought that was one of the more
interesting parts of the essay just
because
that's something that i think uh anyone
who reads a lot of different theory like
will come across thinking like okay like
in this theory like what role is this
concept playing that is being played you
know like i even just think about merlot
and like the habit body and it's like
you know how is that it's like a
different level of description for what
like foucault might be talking about
with the way that power is like is like
um
is uh whatever
put on to bodies uh you know and it's
like there's just different levels of
describing the same thing
and i think that's like
a worthwhile philosophical exercise in
general to like figure out what the
exchange value is and in that sense like
you know what new is actually being
provided by this different way of
framing the phenomenon of of like uh
social interactions in the world like
what's actually being added if anything
at all or is it just a different word to
describe something that's already being
described uh in another theory so yeah i
thought that was interesting i'm not
sure where i stand because as i said i
haven't really read to liz so i don't
know how how much of a role
or how similar the role is that desire
is playing in in uh angela's as as power
as in foucault well this is what i
wanted to say like just in response
actually to what uh eric was saying and
drawing upon uh bojar's own work on um
you know
signs um
and the kind of way that signs speak to
each other starting with simulacra and
simulacrum right uh because pills
mentioned at the beginning that all
these different thinkers are going to
respond to may 68
in a fundamental way uh and it's worth
noting that this is around this the time
uh when all of them released their first
major works so
beaujolais released um you know uh
towards the political economy of the
sign you know the system of objects in
1968 uh foucault released history of
madness uh daredevil release of
grammatology i think it was in 68 wasn't
it or 66 yeah around that time um so you
know they all burst onto the scene and
they all start to adopt this very punk
attitude uh towards the events of mace
1968 where as pill says they become
increasingly iconoclastic right
you know you have foucault with his
leather jacket talking constantly about
power
deluge referencing things like the
american beat poets and the potential
they have to give you a kind of vision
of an emancipated life but i don't think
anybody went as far uh in an almost
nihilistic direction uh as somebody like
beaujolais and i mean that in a positive
sense you know i'm not being pejorative
here uh because the sense that i got
from reading this essay is that foco for
all he becomes a kind of punk
criticizing conventional materialism is
still attracted to this idea that we
need to analyze society in terms of
power dynamics and commit ourselves to
an emancipatory politics
of self-creation there's still this kind
of ethical project underpinning it uh
and a kind of residual belief that
history can be changed um by
restructuring society um but of course
you know you see somebody like beauty
art he was always unafraid of saying
things like look there's all these
french philosophers talking about why we
need to protest the gulf war the gulf
war never happened right it
occurred on tv uh he had this famous
expression when he was asked to kind of
give a report on the war he said well i
don't want to go to
saudi arabia to report on the gulf war i
want to watch it on cnn because that's
where the war is actually going to be
waged you know in the television sets of
the american people right
and
it's very easy to see why he would kind
of take this hyper iconoclastic almost
cheerfully nihilistic standpoint if you
read his work right
the kind of
struggles for emancipation that earlier
materialists including himself and
system objects uh wanted to commit
themselves to is predicated on the
belief that we can actually change real
social relations but we've now gone away
from that we've entered into a hyper
real realm uh where we're never going to
be able to get connection to reality
again and be able to change it uh all
that we're left now with is the
opportunity to manipulate different
kinds of signs in different ways right
some of them might be more creative some
of them might be less creative but
that's what we're left with in our kind
of post-modern era right well it's very
cynical idea but it's kind of it's very
tantalizing right
you're forgetting about the whole idea
of symbolic exchange because one thing
that capitalist societies do not know
how to do is
symbolize death
they only symbolize it as a nothing and
where he said we can if we can
resuscitate death
it can't be exchanged for anything oh
that's right yeah yeah that's a really
interesting thing because he takes his
he takes some cues from uh the
anthropologist marcel mouse right and i
think that's how you pronounce his name
who did uh
i guess he did some some ethnography of
uh of uh was it northwestern american
aboriginal peoples and and the thing he
called the potlash
which was which which was the i i'm
gonna terribly explain it but it's this
sort of this idea within
their society and how symbolic exchange
works of somebody being ready to
exchange everything to die
in a sense within
as as part of the conditions of the
exchange whereas that sort of thing is
is uh unfamiliar to capitalist modes of
exchange i don't know if anyone can step
in and and do a way better job than i
just did of talking about potlash
well it's the yeah it's the gift it's a
gift in which things are not equivalent
whereas
capitalism makes everything equivalent
to itself everything can be you know
bought but also in a theoretical sense
everything can be represented and then
you get these
theorists that are supposedly
anti-capitalism and you can just
exchange all their
concepts between each other too so if we
had a true understanding of death back
then we could actually do violence to
the system he writes about uh terrorism
or like
theoretical terrorism on his book on the
two towers and he wants to be a
a theoretical terrorist because you
can't exchange it for anything yeah here
i think it's actually worth justif
uh sorry i'll just be very quick
juxtaposing his work against adorn on
horkheimer we all know how adorable and
horkheimer despise disney right sawdust
disney is a very dangerous figure the
main proponent of the culture industry
who is peddling tripe uh that was
convincing people not to emancipate
themselves but instead to kind of
liquidate uh their critical
consciousness uh in various forms of
one-dimensional entertainment uh
beaujord apparently went to disney world
and said uh euro disney world and he
said that he loved it right he's like
why would i want to go to europe if i
could go to euro disneyland you know the
food is better i can go to belgium
france italy all in the course of five
minutes uh it's cheaper than having to
travel around
and
again you know this might seem like a
kind of trite observation and it's
definitely quirky and funny but i think
it really goes to show you how
deeply skeptical he was of this idea
that anything like orthodox critical
theory could now get us out of the trap
that we're in uh there's no point in
being cynical about disneyland any
longer the way that adorno and
harkheimer worlds because we are faced
with the disney vacation not just of our
culture any longer but the
disney vacation of all relations uh
within our life according to the logic
of exchange value
well you you can see his post-human bent
in this uh
we we don't know how to die anymore we
don't know how to die because our entire
cities are cities of death they're all
necropolises he says what is an
acropolis exactly
just the the cemetery district where you
do burials and
rituals related to death oh those
mausoleums
pills earlier you were saying about that
like you know foucault and de luz are
supposedly kind of like
reproducing a description that is like
consistent i guess with the flows of
capital
and i'm wondering is this critique like
because i guess you know as being
someone who who is like
early inspired to do continental
philosophy from phenomenology and
existentialism and
um you know i guess there's a there's a
tension maybe in like what is philosophy
supposed to be doing is it supposed to
be a descriptive endeavor or is it
supposed to be like somehow a normative
like inherently a normative endeavor and
maybe i'm maybe i'm i'm misunderstanding
this but
you know is it is it beaujord's viewer
it sounds from what you're saying that
beaujord's view is that um philosophy
must be trying to undermine the existing
structures
therefore just like to so even if
foucault is describing that power is
flowing in this way
that is an accurate description to some
extent of the way the world is it's like
is foucault is is beau gerard's claim
that by describing it you're somehow
reinforcing it and and if that's the
case that seems strange to me but
capitalism and schizophrenia i mean it's
in the title right of of course it's
about capitalism
um
but i think back to the 68 thing his
what he's upset about is that they're
all they're all pretending like they're
radicals they pretend like they're
writing against the system we're gonna
bring it down and that's their intention
and this is like uh foucault's
personality he's like oh he's the he's
the ultimate punk kind of like matt said
but he's not if that's the case then
he's just what bulgaria calls he says in
this he's the mirror the mirror of
capitalism is just uh
foucault's theory and because it's so
perfect that's pretending
like capitalism is perfect like it
doesn't have cracks in it like it can't
be resisted like it can exchange
everything for everything so if that's
your if that's your attitude then i
think he would think that's
counter-revolutionary and not what
theory is supposed to be doing
right okay so it is supposed to be
somehow revolutionary and i mean it's
interesting because i do remember when i
was reading foucault you know that
that there is a lot like i remember a
lot of students in the seminar that i
was in
you know there is kind of an under like
the tone that foucault uses right when
he's describing power it's very ominous
and it's got it's like very um scary
it's got a normative bent to it but
ultimately like it really is a
description
says that yeah he describes it as truth
and you know when you read the
description at least in you know
discipline and punish in some and some
of his other stuff around the same time
right it really does kind of sound like
there's no way of getting out of it
right even though he's talking about
these these the power and these dynamics
in a way that makes it sound like it's
bad
but he's and i guess you know at the
time i was like well he's just offering
a description and you know from my sort
of
outlook of being uh you know kind of for
coming from a phenomenologist at the
time perspective i was like oh well
that's fine doing a description of power
structures there's nothing and then it's
someone else's job you know to come
along with the description and be like
well here's how we can undermine uh
these power structures like um so yeah
but even aside from the revolutionary
aspect of it we have to remind our
listeners and maybe even ourselves that
this is after each of them had published
like two or three books this is halfway
through he's not talking about delizi's
philosophical project that comes later
he's not talking about foucault's
biopolitics that comes later it's
basically the history of sexuality era
and the capitalism and schizophrenia
uh era
i mean and in a sense just to go back
over a couple things i think
yeah in a way the the sort of perfect
reflection of the flows of power or the
flows of desire
this perfect reflection idea is
yeah he's commenting on it being a
descriptive enterprise
and and to that extent like you know all
description is normative there's no
there's no two ways about it all
representation is normative because it
says this is how you should see this
this phenomenon is thus it is always
normative so they're very they're very
very attuned to that sort of idea
and i wouldn't i i wouldn't i don't know
if he's he's using sort of hegel's idea
of philosophy here and reversing it in a
way but you know like
maybe i'm paraphrasing this wrong but in
hegel's view philosophy is is meant to
grasp the current historical moment and
as a result of that it can only sort of
come afterwards right in in order to do
this but what what
beaudry art is saying here and i'm just
like peppering a quote in he's saying
the very perfection of this analytical
chronicle of power is disturbing
and then skipping he says if it is
possible at last to talk with such
definitive understanding about power
sexuality the body and discipline even
down to their most delicate
metamorphoses it is because at some
point all this is here and now over with
and that goes back again to the idea
that
you know if if we can so perfectly grasp
the workings of some system whether it's
a system of power or flows of capital or
desire
if we can grasp these all the way down
to their molecular minutia
i think in a sense it's irrelevant to
the current moment now like it's been
done with and i think that links to the
later idea of the messiah is always
going to come late
the messiah always comes
sort of a day after the revolution has
been completed
you know then and really this is all to
find another way of talking about
revolution that isn't in itself
kind of counter revolutionary because
you really only have two binaries here
you have the bourgeois or you have
revolution or you have something that's
just stuck in the middle and kind of
just floundering within the system
well i'm going to put it somewhat
different way because when i was reading
his ruminations about foucault's theory
of power which i thought were really
smart uh a quote occurred to me i think
it was by laka but it might be from zija
kind of paraphrasing the call
where he says if you're looking at a
parade with the king and his soldiers
there are two mistakes that people can
make the first one is the petition can
actually assume that the king is a king
in himself but the second mistake is
that the king can assume that he's a
king in himself without all the peasants
believing him to be such uh and what i
think uh beautiful are saying here is
look this idea that you've come across
infuko is that power is something real
in fact it's so real that it's
omnipresent it kind of filters through
everything and what we need to recognize
is that power is actually a kind of
abstraction right it only exists to the
extent that we allow it to exist right
uh emerging from our subjectivity and
filtering through our institutions and
via political economy and so the more
radical gesture isn't to say something
like foucault does uh as victor put it
this kind of dismal gloomy
uh claim that power is omnipresent and
everywhere as to say something like
power doesn't exist anywhere unless we
believe it to exist and allow it to
exist
in our kind of hyper-real universe right
now and so he's almost standing aside
outside of society and mocking it for
the pretense of believing that we are
actually living in this huge
disciplinary evil system
and then this is inexorable and there's
nothing we can do about it when this is
really just the product
of
discourses and human imaginations right
yeah and i will say too you know that
that
when i i remember also a big argument in
seminar when i was reading foucault
was like it doesn't seem like there's
any way out of this and i would be
curious
to hear from the people here who are
more familiar with de las pils or maybe
eric
um you know like do you get a similar
sense from de lis right that that it's
like there's no way out of this process
or like is it or is it even like do you
find it like i would like to know if if
that's like a can if there really is a
parallel between the way de la sets
things up in the way foucault sets
things up and in the sense that there's
it's a mirror and it's not clear how you
could get out of it it's kind of like
all-encompassing you just need to smoke
more cigarettes in order to comprehend
this victor that's the key to every
french philosopher yeah we're french
cigarettes i don't know i mean i
i tried to kill that i tried to kill
that like reaction in me i always sent
that natural like idea of like okay how
do we get out of it or like how what's
the cash out here i try to like kill
that
in me because i find it just gets in the
way of reading the actual text and
trying to understand the thinker from
like top to bottom instead of jumping to
okay what are like the cliff notes here
because like
yeah i mean with people as as sort of
i don't say totalizing but yeah there's
there's not a whole lot of room for
human agency in foucault or baudrillard
and so that leads you to the conclusion
that will then like what is done
delusions really all i mean the lu i
wouldn't say that about de luz because
agency and desire play a huge role at
least the language of it does but more
so in foucault and baudrillard you know
foucault has the genealogical method
and i think what beaudry art is
introducing here is more of talking
about simulation
as a sort of baseline methodological
reference for his work now and saying
that you know the genealogical method
has only gotten us so far
but what they do build around those
methods is like this very totalizing
system that seems to have
no agency in it
and that was a big debate you know like
structure of agency and githubs and
things like that and like texts like
that we're thinking about where can
agency come into play and that seems to
say well there's nothing that can be
done but i think there are
ways that these things play out that you
do have to sort of pay attention to
instead of
instead of
getting discouraged by the fact that
yeah even like the adorno horkheimer
vision of the culture industry right
like there's nothing you can do
i think instead of getting discouraged
by that too early you have to kind of
put yourself in a mode where you're
going to you're going to persevere and
try to get everything out of this text
before then asking the okay what now
questions sure sure i i agree with you
but i can answer that question
so he's responding to again capitalism
and schizophrenia
and the goal of that book or those books
um anti-oedipus is let's free desire
because desires are being managed
controlled by the psychoanalysts by
the education system whatever
by capitalism and like he says or like
deliza and qatari say
yeah desire does
mimic the form of capitalism but you can
also direct desire because it's
productive
and then later on later deliz says we
can actually create or produce in
beaujolais terms we can produce our way
out of this by inventing
concepts by by mapping things together
by echoing the history of philosopher
philosophy if you're a philosopher
that's kind of your task
now if we can set up an imaginary debate
about how beaujolais would respond to
that if he's taking this line
i think beaudry would ask the liz again
he says okay you're creating concepts
and you want these concepts to echo
through the history of philosophy and
and and create new ways of thinking now
how do you know that you're just not
creating a new sign
yeah so that would be the question and i
don't i'm not smart enough to have an
answer to that maybe some grad student
out there has written a paper on it but
i don't have an answer to that i think
this is another
this is definitely
another way beaudrillard would question
what you were saying
is he would he would look at the way
that you know i guess he would remind
the losing guthrie so your concept of
desire is born out of a
you're not happy with lacan's idea of
desire as lack as something negative so
what you've done is you've turned it
around
and taken this sort of
what
what baudrillard calls a negative
reactive transcendental concept
and you've turned it into something
positive active and imminent in the
system so
what he says here is that the new
version of desire proposed by de luz and
by leotard because leotard's also
talking about intensities and tensors
proposed by delusion leotard but there
instead of a lack or interdiction that
means you know
you're not allowed to do something an
interdiction instead of a lack or an
interdiction one finds the deployment of
the positive dissemination of flows and
intensities such a coincidence is not
accidental it's simply that in foucault
power power takes the place of desire
so he he's he's attuned to that
that idea of positivity of production of
desiring machines as productive machines
as it essentially being a positive
rather than negative concept
but he's still not
happy with it because he thinks it's i
think near the end he come he starts
coming to say again it's it's one-sided
because it only has that positive aspect
it doesn't have the negative side where
i guess it's another reversal here
because he's all about reversals instead
of irreversible processes it doesn't
have that negative side where power
comes back and acts upon itself in a
certain way
it becomes sort of crystallized and
frozen in the moment of your analysis
rather than being allowed to
continue to sort of collapse in on
itself he says that delusion guitarist's
desire is quote just a savage
naturalism unquote which is basically
saying you're just putting a new name
onto
human labor power
and then
calling it productive desire
so he he's basically reinstating and
here's
beaujord's big problem he's basically
just reinstating human nature but giving
it a different name now i don't think
that's correct all the way down because
that
desiring production
is not at all a human
function really i don't think it's i
don't think it's nearly as naturalist as
beaujohart is claiming and i would
criticize him on that point but again i
don't know
i mean this is a a lot of it comes from
later de las which i have the benefit of
history i can read back into
the first book which baudrillard did not
have
yeah naturalization would be to say i
think they're following like um
the idea of mythology as a as a force
which naturalizes something it makes it
seem universal and ahistorical and
apolitical that's what sort of
naturalizing something does so you kind
of take it out of any kind of possible
historical dialectic and hold it up as
like ah here is a fundamental principle
on on which to build other analyses
which in a very very roundabout way sort
of goes back to descartes idea of like
what's the first thing that we can be
certain of like the i think
and then from there you can build a
whole you can erect an entire foundation
for for knowledge to be built upon
so i think i don't think it's the same
critique obviously against duluth as it
would be
when they're talking about descartes but
i think it has a similar tenor in my
mind well i wanted to frame it in a
somewhat different way which is that if
you think back to the history of
european philosophy uh i prefer the term
european philosophy to western
philosophy which i think is a lot more
problematic but anyway lost
there's always been uh a series of
ironists who have appeared uh that prick
holes in any effort uh for to engage in
philosophical or political systematicity
uh you can think of somebody like
socrates you could think of somebody
like sauron kierkegaard who's responding
to hegel uh and i think you could also
include somebody like jean baudrillard
and for that matter jacques derida in
this list of a kind of minor literature
of figures right um because again what
you really saw was somebody like
deliz
and for that matter also with co is an
attempt to engage in a kind of critical
system building even if it was opposed
to previous systems uh that had been
existent uh like you really difference
in your repetition uh there's still this
very clear desire to go from ontological
foundationalism of a certain kind uh the
university of being
to an argument for the need to respect
difference in and of itself
and then to an argument as pills put it
later on in antiopus
that different kinds of beings should be
able to liberate their desires in a
certain way to engage in schizoid lives
of a certain sword foco isn't quite as
normative as de liz is
but again he still is has a very very
clear systematic or at least
archetectonic account of society and
near the end of his life he was getting
very close to starting to argue for a
nietzschean ethics of self-creation you
know with a little bit of can't thrown
in uh and beaujolais seems to me to be
very much like somebody somebody likes
socrates or kierkegaard or daredevil for
that matter who comes along and anytime
someone tries to do this is just going
to mock it relentlessly because the
account of agency and liberation that's
present with them is much more
anti-intellectualist in a certain sense
because what they're trying to say is
that if you want to be free from the
concepts of ideology you also need to
liberate yourself from the concepts of
theory which means to take an ironic
distance towards everything right uh and
in a certain sense that's what he's
doing in this piece by insisting that we
take an ironic distance from this kind
of archetectonic thinking that you or
you see
in de las and foucault which can very
easily set themselves up as new kinds of
totalizing ideologies
but totalizing discourses uh even if
they're critical discourses so you think
bojar is just a perpetual edgelord yeah
that's basically what i'm saying right i
mean he is offering some other ideas
he's not just saying no no no he's also
saying like this is a better way to do
it he offers some like positive ideas i
mean obviously this whole article that
we're reading here is framed as a
critique so you're gonna get a lot of
that but he is he does suggest his own
better quotes method and do you guys
remember what's the book that foucault
because darida makes a lot of the same
charges in different language but a lot
of the same charges against foucault and
foucault wrote a book
back to him was it kogiro and madness
uh i can't remember the name of the
paper but yeah it was primarily about
the interpretation of reason and the
kugito uh in that first book the history
of madness and they had an exchange on
the subject matter i mean if i remember
correctly it wasn't an explicit response
to derrida but he tried to respond
anyway but it's interesting that
de lis and derida and beau gerard have
also the similar
uh vein of critique against foucault
but uh baudrillard got the worst end of
the stick on it seems like
he did it too early
i want to say that i agree with eric
right that i'm not saying that you know
an ironist of this sort ever just sits
there and says no no no our trash is
everybody like an ed lord
edgelord you know al victor right i mean
if you think about somebody like
kierkegaard or socrates or daredev right
the act of deconstructing or engaging in
socratic questioning uh or revealing you
know the instability of hegel's system
uh does have a productive dimension to
it because it allows you to take a kind
of cognitive distance uh between
yourself and theories that are setting
themselves up as alternatives of
somewhere in some way shape or form
right and i think there are limitations
to this kind of philosophical approach
uh because i think some ways it can
become a lot more nihilistic even than
something like foucaultianism for all
its problems right but it's also really
refreshing sometimes to read somebody
who
is so completely
iconoclastic to use pills terms and so
irreverent that he's not even going to
truck any kind of systematic [ __ ] uh
from other critical philosophers anytime
they try to set this stuff up he's just
going to be there to knock it down a
couple pegs by saying stop trying to
re-totalize
power
as a substitute for classical political
economy or sex or whatever it happens to
be now i'm just not going to let that
happen
so as a side note i would say that
european philosophy is a much worse
choice you couldn't do worse than
choosing to replace the idea of western
philosophy with european philosophy
western philosophy has has its downfall
but i mean european philosophy oh my god
where were from plato and socrates
europeans that's that's debatable and
and then
that ignores the entire sphere of
eastern influence not only that made its
way into the hellenic world but also
during the islamic middle ages when they
had their renaissance and
you know early modern philosophy got a
massive kick in the ass from eastern
ideas and that sort so it's very very
problematic
it's just that the reason i don't like
western philosophy is i think the whole
concept of western civilization is
deeply offensive reason being having
spent some time in mexico that despite
speaking european languages worshiping
the same god uh and you know having the
same form of government for some odd
reason people in latin america and for
that matter elsewhere uh don't get to be
part of the western world for reasons i
think that have more to do with their
skin color than anything else so i think
what european philosophy is also hugely
problematic i just find it somehow less
noxious in this notion that there's
something like western civilization and
i mean it's funny when you when you when
you said that when you said european
philosophy i actually always think about
um just like what what a lot of people
call continental philosophy because i
noticed that like in a lot i notice on a
lot of like phd programs a lot of
departments like university apartments
like they will sometimes say european
philosophy as a euphemism for
continental philosophy uh they'll talk
about like as opposed to yeah and
there's journals too like the european
legacy and stuff which is basically just
continental philosophy journal but i did
i did want to pick up on something that
that eric said earlier to kind of bring
it back to the way that pills set this
all up as in the context of 68 right and
like because because i mean i'm
interested in this claim that beaudry
art is making that supposedly you know
the foucaulty inner delusion
views are somehow counter-revolutionary
because they are mirroring right and
you know i think uh but then eric you
were talking about how a lot of
baudrillard's philosophy
al also leads to
like how do we get out of this kind of
thing and i do want to also by the way
agree with you um you know that that i
don't think the right way to approach
these texts or content or european
philosophy whatever
is to be like okay how do we get out of
this right you have to take it up you
have to take the philosophy up that's
why i i'm actually you know have no
problem with descriptive philosophical
accounts because they're incredibly
valuable and you just want to take up
the description and see where see where
it takes you but
you know it was interesting that you you
said
beaudry art kind of also leads to this
conclusion that you might have from
foucault that there's like no way to get
out of these
systems but then like the way pills set
up this conversation was supposedly
beaudrier's critique of these guys is
that they're counter-revolutionary
because their systems are just mirroring
uh capitalism as this kind of system
that you can't do anything about so i
don't know if there's if there's a way
to untangle those things or
yeah i mean i think they're all
looking at the 68 revolution quote like
quote unquote revolution it was kind of
a failed revolution right and they're
thinking about
again
why has this revolution failed
and what can we do differently
yeah i mean it's tough you can sort of
parse it out a little further and say
it's
maybe it's not that they're they're
counter revolutionary but but that what
they're describing
because it's become so clear and
minutely describable that it is no
longer a kind of
revolution to even describe the workings
of power and desire anymore
by when did this come out 1976
or something like that so that's like
it's like less than a little less than
10 years of reflection
on on 68
which was one of those like 9 11 events
for those guys back in that this time
and they're thinking why like why
what can we do differently now i guess
is to say
i think people don't appreciate how
huge an influence this has had on french
philosophers if they're not kind of
mired in that field uh like alain biju
who i don't like very much uh released a
very nice little book called you know
the pantheon uh which is just his
account of the french philosophers but
one of the things that he opens with is
that he's actually the last surviving
member of the 68 generation that's how
he understands himself philosophically
right uh there were all these guys they
wrote their books he was a bit of a late
bloomer you know kind of emerging in the
1980s uh but he says i remember this
happening we were all kind of
inspired by it you know and then we all
tried to look for the solutions for why
it failed although zero had his account
poco had his account you know deluse and
qatari had their account uh and so
here's my kind of
history uh of these movements right
right in truth
beaudry art has written a very quotable
text here one of them
to this point he says in the end the
revolution signifies only this
that it has already taken place and that
it had a meaning just before one day
before but not anymore now
when it comes it is to hide the fact
that it is no longer meaningful
and so again with this the the idea of
the the reversal effect
is that
once you've sort of
rely once you've
like noticed that the revolution is here
that it's happening that we can talk
about it now it's it's already it's
already lost its revolutionary potential
it's already
it's already gone
in a sense and this this goes back to
the idea of the simulacrum i guess how
it sort of re-doubles
things like you have you have on the on
the one side you have
i mean i'm i'm just grasping now but you
know on the one side you have repression
and on the other side you have
liberation of desire and those he says
kind of you can't really talk about
those
apart in in the sense that they both
rely on one another
to function in the world you can't talk
about
oppression without
oppressed you can't talk about these
things
separately because they function
together as like almost as a single unit
and i i think he's charging foucault and
and deluz a little bit of doing this of
of separating
the liberation of desire
or sexual liberation from the repression
of desire and repression
of liberate of of uh of sexuality right
because foucault's
ideas are about
i mean they're it's so complex because
obviously we're
already past all these major thinkers
who've gone into great detail about this
stuff but the idea of that sort of
william reich this second generation
freudian
who had these ideas about sexuality and
getting people to
you know like gyrate and express
themselves and almost go into like
catatonic states of self-expression
where they lose all control and just
scream and shout and yell
and and all of this is somehow has a
kind of revolutionary or not maybe
liberatory kind of effect on society if
everyone would just allow themselves to
be more open about their sexuality and
talk about it more foucault's already
calling this
the the remnants of a confessional kind
of
culture
and and so we've already got this
amazing like you read foucault and you
look at that you're like oh my god okay
yeah that's great how can you get any
further than that and then you have
beaudrier coming along saying well
you've actually just separated
liberation from
repression and they're actually two
sides of the same coin and so how okay
there now there's a new statement in the
philosophical field how do we process
baudrillard's
contribution to this can i answer do you
want to say that i think oh sorry i just
want to say i do think he misinterprets
foucault pretty badly here uh in the
history of sexuality in particular right
because while reading volume one which i
imagine uh
i think had just been released or by all
that wasn't even out yet um you know
foucault does sometimes write in terms
of the repressive hypothesis and
interrogating it but certainly if you
look at the whole ubra he's very clear
about the fact that this idea that there
was a repressive time period that we're
now liberating ourselves from uh is kind
of a fantasy uh and he takes a much more
productive
yeah no i wasn't saying beaudry art
makes that mistake
knows what foucault's all about here and
he's trying to now like offer a new
statement into that sort of
up which already seemed to me almost
complete saying yeah it's confessional
you know asking people to
express themselves as a kind of
confessional gesture and i thought wow
it doesn't get any more like
like deeply critical than that and then
you have here beaudry art coming along
saying something new finding room for
critique of that that's very interesting
but this is what i'm saying i think that
the two of them coincide in their views
on this a lot more than this article
would suggest right no no they don't
they don't here's why what's happening
here foucault's
thesis of sexuality is supposed to be
contrary and contrary to the freudian
one right that freud defines sexuality
as repression primarily symptoms of
repression so for foucault it's not
repression but compelled expression like
you just said matt but that when it
appears it's controlled in my new detail
so
who who can you [ __ ] when can you [ __ ]
them is like a moral act
president clinton did you penetrate her
face or her body what like what exactly
did you do did you bust or did you not
bust
i did not are you
are you a homosexual are you a bisexual
and what percentage are you does your
film have one breast in it or is there
two because then you're gonna get a
higher rating so it's that sexuality is
micromanaged this is foucault's thesis
by the way it's micromanaged in every x
in every appearance but it's also
compelled to express
or to be expressed so you have to have
like a sexual identity you have to
define yourself by that whereas in a
repressive society it wasn't like that
so that's the foucault thesis but
beaujohn here is suspicious about this
thesis that says
um everything is micromanaged because he
says no sexuality when pornography
proves it sexuality is not being
compelled it's already disappeared there
is no reality to sexuality this is just
pure exchange at this point and we still
want to believe in it so we can talk
about whether the repressive hypothesis
is true or the the expressive hypothesis
is true but the fact is the thing's
already gone and then to turn it into a
theoretical object then then you're then
you're like one further step removed
which is why he calls it a mirror so at
this point when we're talking about
sexuality in those terms it's not just a
mirror but it's a mirror of a mirror
which is of course the definition of
hyper reality so it's exchanged at this
level where none of those questions even
make a difference anymore so he says
something like foucault has a
magisterial theory of sexuality too bad
sexuality is already gone and doesn't
exist anymore
yeah i i'm finding these sort of newer
ways of latching on to at least like de
luz but i don't think beaudry art would
be against this is to is to think about
why do we always like what is this
opposition between the molar and the
molecular or the discursive and
and sort of micro power microfascism
that sort of idea is because what we're
on the one hand we're dealing with molar
or discursive phenomena things you can
see things you can interact with things
that are on the plane of order things
that are in the world of the visible
right and then you have all these other
ideas that work behind that the
invisible molecular
intensities affects power those sorts of
things that work behind the scenes in a
sort of subversive way
and you know we all know the capitalism
is in itself a subversive
kind of thing right that's like one of
marx's basic statements about capitalism
is like constant revolution and so you
know delusion
and foucault is extremely brilliant
insight was to let's sort of appropriate
that revolutionary force and except
they're going to talk about it in terms
of the molecularization of desire and
those sorts of ideas
and and baudrillard and what i'm seeing
in these sorts of newer appropriations
too is to actually give the molar some
room get give the discursive or the
realm of appearance or simulacrus some
room to be revolutionary in a sense
because they like i said they are kind
of two sides of the same coin you don't
have the molar without the molecular and
the other way around as well
and what i'm seeing here is a kind of
willingness to
not always associate
you know discurse with
discourse with with these sorts of
subversive levels of being power laden
like let let it be what it is and then
we can sort of look at it and and talk
about what's invisible here but first we
have to go through the visible sort of
thing
okay this is where i want to come in and
just defend my argument that they're
actually closer than bojar is making it
out to be uh i think that certainly
there are elements of poco's work that
would make you think that he's
centralizing an account of sexuality in
this kind of magisterial fashion and the
fact that he wrote three now four
volumes on the subject you know
testifies to that but i think if you
look in his work voco is very cognizant
of the fact that this kind of hyper
fixation on the importance of sexuality
and sexual identity is extremely
problematic and has been problematic
from the very beginning uh and in fact
one of the comments that he makes about
his own sexual identity or at least the
one that he's tagged with as a gay uh in
man
is that he wants to resist being
ascribed or interpolated in this fashion
and one of the things that he says about
homosexuality that's quite interesting
is that
what's provocative about it isn't
necessarily that it shows you uh that we
could we could have two men who enter
into a sexual relation together with
either but that it shows you that
different kinds of social organization
are possible than the ones that are
conceived of in our current sexual
regimes right and they don't necessarily
have to be sexual relations
uh and he doesn't really develop this in
great detail uh because he died of aids
right uh but it seems like he was moving
in the direction that beaudry art is
arguing not necessarily the stuff about
hyper reality uh but being antagonistic
to this majestic uh conception of sex
like you're talking about i mean i don't
know if he would carry i would have
carried on this way had he lived but
that's just my take on it well he says
that i mean he's using uh
foucault's understanding of sexuality as
a metaphor for power which is what
foucault does as well uh power knowledge
is a single concept but beaujord's claim
is that that thing needs you to believe
that exists
not that it exists so believing that it
exists and investing all this energy
into it was for him the french left's
fault because the political sphere had
already been destroyed
and then you're reinvesting all this
meaning to it and you could i mean i
could i don't want to jump into
analogies to today
but you know what i'm thinking right he
says uh here's quote its strategy is in
fact always creating a space of optical
illusion maintaining itself in total
ambiguity total duplicity
in order to throw others into this space
yeah i love that what i'm just trying to
say
is that foucault is sometimes read
uh as agitating for kind of
micropolitics of identity and i
certainly think that you can see
elements of that in his work and the
kind of causes that he supported right
uh and
so we have to be careful here but i do
think that if you read particularly his
later work again stuff near the end of
his life he was becoming increasingly
critical of this in a way that would
later echoed by gender theorists like
judith butler who's extremely critical
of identity politics ironically enough
when you think about the discourse
around her because you know again what
foco says isn't that we should
centralize the emancipation of sexual
identities or refocus our attention on
the construction of new sexual
identities in a kind of rote way
but see the interrogation of sex as an
opportunity to think about how it is
that human subjects are created and how
it is that we can move past these kind
these kinds of political systems and
power dynamics uh in order to conceive
new modes of existence that might not
have anything to do with sexuality per
se uh particularly given the way that
sexuality has become so centralized and
commodified in late capitalist society
and there's been some very interesting
focali and work done on this you know a
very good example is uh how it is that
um
focal talks about prostitution in 19th
century uh england and how even at this
point sex was becoming increasingly
commodified during a time period where
apparently the repressive hypothesis
hypothesis or sorry repressive uh
viewpoints were ubiquitous right uh it's
where you see this extreme
disconnect appearing between the desire
of capital to commodify sexuality uh and
on the other hand the victorian ethos
and the power associated with that still
trying to impose this kind of moral view
on society so there's a lot of ways that
you can kind of complicate this pakodian
narrative i mean you're not wrong but
you're reading a lot into it
you're you're being you're being extra
extra charitable i am i i like those
words of course we can we can come back
and defend foucault later and no knocks
on the guy and not saying that he didn't
like sort of modify his views even maybe
he secretly read this article and really
took it to heart and wrote his later
books with it in mind but i mean i'm
just interested right now and sort of
sussing out what beaudry art is saying
in this article rather than sort of
leaping to the defense of of each of
those who he's
wronged with his
out of nowhere
unknown intellectual at the time
attacking the bigwigs
who needs your defense they need us to
jump to our their defense we could mount
a robust
defense on behalf of the people we like
being
being called out here but the purpose of
the episode is
review someone else's
challenge
sure and also you know i mean
these dead guys who who's going to speak
for them yeah yeah it's not a good read
though is just a quotable
factory right
yeah such good lines
yeah but you know on the on the point of
like the critique i'm kind of curious
pills like like do you or generally
speaking like find that beaudry arts
critiques here are fair like you don't
have to go into detail like
like because as we said we're not going
to try to defend uh
delize and and foucault but like i'm
just kind of curious on your take like
generally speaking well they're fair and
so far as we've we've read this in a lot
of graduate seminars right and i think
people read foucault rightly and they
come away with the same feeling that
it's like
oh power is just everything okay now
what so i think that part is correct
um not not right now extending to
biopolitics which is a little a little
different from that um but with respect
to delis and gatari
they said that they were doing this it's
not like beaujolais is pointing at
something that they didn't know they
were doing
like talking about
deterritorializing flows and they say
capitalism is like the
the productive desiring machine par
excellence
um
i don't have the quote in front of me
but it's from uh desert islands i think
so
they said they were doing that and then
the question is should philosophy be
doing that or not should it be doing
something else and to that i have
absolutely no answer i don't know what
philosophy should be doing
i mean yeah i mean i don't actually like
the idea of somebody being like that
philosophy shouldn't be doing this like
you know like i think
my kind of ad hoc reaction to that is
just like well i don't think
uh like i don't i just don't like the
idea and principle of people being like
well philosophy shouldn't be doing that
it should be doing this it's like i
don't know that's has to be much more
free flowing than that i think
and the answer to that might be that
everyone that everyone is heralding this
is like the most revolutionary
philosophy and it might be as simple as
budra is pointing out you know that's
not true this is not the most
revolutionary philosophy it's just
mirrored production
um and if that's the case then then fair
enough that's a fair critique yeah but
it depends and i don't want to answer
this for anybody but what do you think
theory should be doing and i don't even
yeah that's why i hesitate to answer i
stutter to answer that point because i
don't think that's for me to say i'm a
youtuber yeah i agreed well we know that
victor is a maoist you know let a
thousand flowers bloom so
there's that answer settled there no but
i i think i mean i i agree i don't want
to be this the person to say like what's
what what should or shouldn't be
philosophy or or theory yeah
yeah at this point i would have a hard
time even drawing a line between
philosophy and other disciplines i mean
bucco himself ran into this difficulty
and i would argue beaudrier fits into it
too is he a media theorist is he a
cultural critic is he a philosopher is
he kind of a weird marxist who knows is
piccolo nichian a kantian a historian of
ideas a commentator of society who knows
um
i i think it's an interesting question
and if i thought about it a little bit
more i could come up with a better
answer i just think it's so hard to
demarcate theory today from other
disciplinary activities that we need to
spend at least a little bit of time
trying to come up with a kind of
quasi-essentialist answer about what
we're talking about when we're engaging
in theoretical activities perhaps a
topic for another episode yeah well
that's what i wanted to say something
exactly on those lines is beaudrier was
like ostracized for this and people read
his later work and go you know what the
[ __ ] is this guy talking about but this
shows that he's got some theoretical
chops he's not afraid to go after people
he was like
everyone basically took foucault's side
as far as i've read and can tell and
beaudrier had a lot more difficult time
getting jobs
than foucault did and i'm not sure why
beaudry went the way he went which is
far less argumentative but i think he
tried to bring what he's saying here
into the style where you can't say you
just can't replace
my words with someone else's words
because my words are like oh now i'm
writing in aphorisms so he did
he he made his form
the content of the argument that he's
sort of making here he can't be replaced
there is only like one bull gerard
hmm yeah i mean just to give a testament
to help to speak to your opponent bills
and how famous foucault was um i can't
remember what institution it is it was
the university of paris whatever number
it is eight or nine or 25. uh but they
actually created a special chair just
for him because he didn't like being
called the philosopher kind of back to
the point he wanted to be the historian
a historian of ideas right and he was so
famous at this point that the university
was like if you [ __ ] want to do that
call yourself it we don't give a [ __ ]
you know but it speaks to his
power
that de la's got i mean not to list that
bodriard got uh
he had to go to disneyland by himself
he's riding the tea cup right
all alone
with a cigarette hanging out with
cinderella yeah
just little kids coming up to him
they're like what do you think about
this he's like well enjoy this soon this
will be all your reality and then
there'll be nothing there's only idea
beer staring back at you
i mean the weird thing about it too
though is again he did eventually become
a celebrity i mean this is going to
sound really really cheesy but my first
exposure to his work was in the matrix
you know when
neo picks up the book and it's simulacra
and simulacrum and he opens it up and
there's a little [ __ ] thing in it
simulation
oh sorry yeah excuse me and um you know
i i read that about the guy later on and
i picked it up and i read it and stuff
but
people commented on how weird it is that
beaudry art himself became kind of a
celebrity appearing in hollywood
blockbuster films and
having people argue about his work in
them and stuff you know
yeah i'd say he's a fascinating he's got
a fascinating and
sort of offbeat perspective compared to
all of these other
philosophers theorists whatever you want
to call them uh but but he's also
like i don't get the sense he's doing
anything radically different but he does
have interesting
ideas that feel like they're new
you know just these quotable little
quips like instead of
foucault's functional vision of power
we need to say power is something that
is exchanged
power seduces
and he brings all these different words
in like simulation and simulacrum later
on in a book he publishes a couple years
after this article we're reading
and so he's got a very interesting and
lately on having looked into marshall
mcluhan a little bit more
you know there's a lot of echoes of
mcluhan
in
beaudry art as well
which i find very interesting because i
i find
a lot of thinkers tend not to
address media and technology
or anything in in depth anyway
in in a way that people can find you
know like relatable whereas beaujolais
is giving us that he's giving us this
sort of high philosophy
but you can also think about like our
our surrounding world in it that's very
very mediated by technology and media
and and images and messages and i i
think that's part of what makes beaudry
art extremely
appealing despite this sort of early uh
kerfuffling he had with uh with the
french intellectual community yeah and i
agree with pells completely that
beaujolais i agree this piece is more
dense than some of his later work but
was just fantastic at spinning off
remarkable ideas some of which are a
little underdeveloped but they're
extremely provocative uh i mean in
simulacra and simulacrum uh he has that
famous statement about how he says we
shouldn't even be talking about the real
anymore because we've now entered into
the desert of the reel which is later on
the title of the g-check book and also
appears in the matrix right and that's
extraordinarily provocative right
talking about borja's stories and then
discussing the desert the real or to
title a book you know the golf war never
happened i mean before you even read the
book
you're gonna have a [ __ ] opinion on
it right like something in this visual
is gonna be
there inside of yourself uh wanting to
respond to it or this whole notion of
hyper reality and stuff so just to our
listeners who think that i'm [ __ ] on
him for you know defending foucault and
stuff i think the guy is fascinating
right he's there's few thinkers uh on
the french left that i can conceive of
who are more enigmatic and interesting
than he is i just also find him
frustrating sometimes and just a quick
uh like correction i think before so the
title of the book definitively is
similar simulacra and simulation just to
be clear oh okay there we go i actually
[ __ ] that up all the time always put
simulation first
yeah just say any
any declension it's like bodies without
[ __ ]
organs
and
organized
him okay so as this is
fight night
i don't think it was a knockout but
we're gonna we're gonna have to give it
to the judges see the scorecards to see
whose hand gets raised at the end of
this
uh we are not the judges we'll leave it
to you yeah
hopefully we present today well and can
i just a quick little aside about the
text and i should mention too for the
listeners that this text is very short
like i think the actual the actual text
of the forget uh fuco is only what like
40 pages or something
yeah so
stay tuned for our next fight nights we
have a lot to choose from thankfully
um
maybe give a recommendation if you have
one for us
yeah
but uh we're gonna do a few of these
because they inspire debates on both
sides
and uh interesting interesting content
so
uh thank you guys we'll see you later
[Music]
fatality